[Music]
today we're here to play some Asian
drinking games
it is Friday it is five o'clock I had
nothing to do for the rest of the day so
I'm ready to drink I'm nervous my hands
are clammy
I'm also the world's most competitive
person no competition at all
see that's not your fun fact I have to
present in front of my entire team after
this video and one person will walk out
of here the winner hmm the rest of us
will be on the floor let's get right to
it our first name is from Korea called
Titanic we have beer and soju a beer
glasses filled halfway with beer with
the shock lesson and we take turns
pouring soju in whoever sinks it pass it
down the entire soju bomb you're screwed
like we needed to flow up the glasses
I'm sure that a magic dress oh there it
is one finger oh my god are you David
Blaine right now my
[Music]
in gravity
say goodbye rose cuz this ship is about
to sink oh no no no no bye bond cheers
y'all
[Music]
remember if you see me after great
things get it I get it
[Music]
seven six five the goals not for me that
I choked but it is to burp really loud
when you're done the next game is from
China called finger guessing shooting
out a certain number of fingers while
simultaneously saying a number between
zero and however many fingers are
participated whoever guesses the exact
amount or closest wins and the other two
must drink we're shouting and fingering
at the same time no you guys are
involving numbers and alcohol already
unfucked in this situation let's get the
fingering 21 I said 10 I said 30 I said
30 so you would buy the 22 11 everyone
okay that was that is a very stressful
games a lot of coordination like yes up
a different number than what you're
saying
Cheers being really bad at this a little
embarrassed next up from Japan is the
pocket game two people have to nibble
away for the center of a [ __ ] Allah lady
in the [ __ ] and whoever pulls away
loses and you finish your drink this is
gonna be the most intimate I've ever got
in with a co-worker
so no husband
this could take a turn if you're really
drunk this game is how babies are made
[Music]
that's what he said I love it that's
like this big before
mMmmm really oh I'm so glad I can be
part of this intimate moment here so
we're really close now you're right
start with my final thought so anything
sober I feel happy I feel realize I'm
drugs I'm very excited about all the
games I learned today brings us together
like this now our best friends did not
like the math game that was my favorite
game I was good at counting I honestly
really liked the Pocky game but like
this I could get sort of weird in these
types of games the loser is really the
winner because you get to booze it up
drink responsibly though you know like
drink responsibly I got nervous in the
beginning that I wasn't getting drunk at
night I I sped up that being said do you
want to play hockey pong only a hundred
percent